let's take a look at matt boyd on the
mound for the tigers tonight two and
five
improved tremendously over last year in
his first pitch strike percentage second
in the league on that harold ramirez
batting 246 couple of homers six rbis
indians with a two out base runner no
score in the first
there's a ball scalded right center
field that's in the alliance over banu's
head off to the races is ramirez coming
around third they'll wave him he'll
score without a throw
and staying at second base with a
two-out rbi double is big harrell
harold taking him the other way but he
wastes no time he's going to jump right
on it it's a fastball pretty much middle
of the plate that he shoots the other
way got it past badou
shane bieber will be the indians uh
northeast ohio four dealers starting
pitcher this afternoon and uh shane
going to make his 11th start
and
he's and three at 3 32
going up against this detroit lineup
we're looking for him to to toss a good
one this afternoon the one-two
swing and a weak ground ball to short
gobbled up by chang he'll throw over
the 3-2 swinging a little baby pop up
into shallow center castro got turned
the wrong way now he goes out and he
makes a fine running catch but dude
wasn't going to get there
and harold castro turned right had to go
back left and what a fine play
what that's concentration there because
right now it's a high sky you're running
full speed looking over your shoulder
tracking the ball
should have been a strikeout the next
curve ball is a swing and a miss so
you give shane bieber two strikeouts of
nico goodrum in that at that
first strikeout for shane bieber despite
him saying people aren't swinging at
pitches out of the strike zone as much
this year against him he still has the
most swings and misses like that pitches
out of the strike zone in baseball gets
a second strikeout
and it comes on a good one is this the
curveball or is this the slider
and there is strikeout number 600 for
shane bieber the fastest indians pitcher
to 600 strikeouts
in franchise history
came back with a breaking ball and
struck him out
fourth of the afternoon for bieber
another 3-2 and he struck him out to
make a decision are you going to come or
are you gotta stay back where you gonna
go
one two he got him swinging look like
matt
and all along matt boyd trying to pick
his teammate up
big old curveball right there he's got
it well out front good break you're
gonna sit that bad out and wait for
a fastball or something hard to get
strikes out naylor you think the air
bothered matthew boyd think again
he punches out rosario strikes out you
chang and then sits down josh naylor
swing and a miss the bottom literally
fell out of that off speed pitch five
strikeouts now for bieber
yeah this is a very good curveball right
there on the plate it started at the
knees it disappears
the next several weeks there's a swing
and a bouncing ball to the first baseman
up with it chang flips to bieber
covering and shane bieber records a one
two three fourth inning
he still is not allowed to base it
through four good one harold castro the
double play combination and double play
death boyd sets holds the glove away
from the letters the two ones swinging a
shot to third gathered up by candelario
to castro one relay to first in the dirt
scoop by
inning ending double play for matthew
boyd terrific you have a great job
candelario to castro to scope who makes
another fine play at first we at the
bottom of the fifth inning still one
nothing
swing gonna miss it some high heat and
that is strikeout number six
for shane bieber to come back with the
curveball after the high fastball yeah
i'll tell you what he's filling it up
today he's filling up the quadrants
he digs back in here comes bieber's 0-2
and it's swung on grounded to the second
baseman up with it hernandez throws onto
first in time for the out three up three
down bieber has not allowed to hit
through five harold who drove in the
only run of the game back in the first
right back up the middle and it gets
through ramirez will score and it's two
to nothing cleveland
harold ramirez has driven him both home
today
and it was the exact same situation
very first pitch he comes back
and this one goes right up the middle i
thought they were going to have a play
at it you'll see an infielder go down
and deflect off the mound two-nothing
tribe we're in the sixth
eddie rosario for two today steps in
now the pitch
and it's swung on and this is ripped to
deep right it is gone
a line drive two run home run to right
by eddie rosario and the indians have
opened it up now leading four to nothing
rosario
with his fourth home run a laser to the
seats in right giving him 26 rbis
extending his modest hit streak to seven
games
and the indians have jumped on matthew
boyd for three straight hits and three
runs here in the sixth shane bieber
rolls on bottom of the sixth he has the
number nine hitter willie castro to lead
it off he's allowed only two base
runners a one-out walk to harold castro
in the first a one-out walk to eric haas
in the second nice paint with the heater
second time he's punched out of batter
with a called third strike number eight
on the afternoon when austin hedges came
out and made a nice play tapper by the
mound
they wrote a first to get the out there
and the runner is at second base
going in there again
sure oh yeah
ring them up strikeout number nine for
shane beaver and the beat goes on
through six
jonathan scope the cleanup hitter will
lead off
it's the bottom of the seventh shane
bieber with the no hitter through six
four nothing indians aj hinch says when
you get about six outs away from that no
hit bid that's when you really start
thinking about it
scope drives one to left
there goes the no hitter and the shutout
that was a frozen rope
well he finally got one of those sliders
that didn't slide away from him and he
pounded this first pitch jonathan scope
has had a
pretty aggressive
approach today
and finally gets one up in the zone and
over the fence
swing and a miss he struck him out on a
breaking ball in the dirt pitch
countdown he's at 92. he has thrown 40
curveballs
and 14 sliders
blew the fastball right by him and
that's 11 strikeouts
for shane bieber
blew the fastball right by him for a
dozen strikeout afternoon
the pitch
and it's swung on slice to left down the
line fair ball this will roll towards
the stands kick off the sidewall harold
ramirez is hitting third coming home
relay throw to the plate to slide the
tag safe at the plate the indians take a
five to one lead
on a two out
rbi double down the left field line by
eddie rosario and he does it again off a
left-handed pitcher
another row two
ripped down the right field line
haas will motor to third
and they're gonna wave him home
he will score without a throw
that's an rbi triple for victor reyes
boy victor got that hanger and
down into the right field corner
[Applause]
pops it up
jose ramirez booked it
the indians come to detroit take three
out of four from the tigers